Thank you for your response.
Please discuss your ideas about using different metrics on the forums.
Before we move on to the modeling section,
I would like to give you some food for thought.
As you have seen, distance metrics are very useful.
In our case, we have used the distance metric quite literally to
measure distance between two points on the surface of the earth.
However, when we measure difference between two PDFs or
functions, we can use distances as well.
In the following sections,
we are going to introduce what are called the risk and loss functions.
You will see that the lost function is essentially a distance measurement.
As we move on to build and verify the model,
feel free to use features you chose in the quiz instead or
in addition to our features that we have used so far in the analysis.
And see how the model performs.